Prof: Okay,
so last time we saw the
jeopardy approach to solving the
Schrödinger equation,
which is to take the answer and
find out what the problem was,
and we saw that for a constant
potential you got a sine wave.
You could choose any length of
sine wave you wanted,
any wave period you wanted.
It just turned out to be
different energies and it had a
relationship between the
wavelength and the energy,
the kinetic energy,
or the total energy in that
case.
And we saw an exponential is --
corresponds to --
negative kinetic energy,
which not very many people in
the class liked,
and not very many people ever
like it,
but suck it up because that's
the way kinetic energy is for
small particles.
If you don't like to call it
kinetic energy because you're so
wedded to the fact that for big
things it's ½mv^2,
then just consider it the
difference between total energy
and potential energy.
Okay?
But anyhow it's kinetic energy.
Okay, so we looked at the
jeopardy approach,
to start with the answer and
get the question.
But we'd a lot rather do it the
other direction,
to start with the problem and
find out what the answer is.
And you can do that by guessing
the energy.
If you have a sufficiently
simple system,
that is, one particle in one
dimension;
and this is a great way to get
the idea of what's special about
quantum mechanics,
make it as simple as possible
and then we'll go to realistic
systems.
Okay, so we can rearrange the
Schrödinger equation.
Remember, this is the
Schrödinger equation:
HΨ=EΨ;
divide through by Ψ
and split the
HΨ/Ψ part into
the potential energy part,
V, which is a nothing,
it's given to you,
and the kinetic energy part,
which is a negative constant
that involves the inverse mass
times the curvature of Ψ
over Ψ.
So it has to do with the
shape of Ψ.
And remember,
if you multiply Ψ by
a constant,
you multiply the curvature by
the same constant,
so the kinetic energy stays the
same.
So it's only what we say,
the shape, not really the
amplitude, because that scales
with the curvature.
Okay, but now we can rearrange
this, this way.
So we have a formula here for
the curvature of Ψ.
Now if you have a formula for
the curvature,
if you know how a curve is
going to change,
how a line is going to change
its curvature ,
then you have a recipe for
drawing it,
if you know how to start.
If you start with a certain
height,
and a certain slope -- suppose
you know that,
and you know the curvature,
at that point,
then you know if you take a
little step in that direction
what the next slope is going to
be.
Okay?
Because that's how curved it is.
And if you recalculate and know
the curvature at that point,
then you know what the
curvature at the next point is
going to be,
and the next and the next and
the next,
and you can use this to just
draw a curve that's bound to
satisfy the Schrödinger
equation because you're using
the Schrödinger equation to
generate it.
Does everybody see this?
This is really important.
Do you want me to say it again,
or you got it now?
If you have a formula for the
curvature --
that's how fast the slope is
changing --
and if you know the initial
height and the initial slope,
then if you know the direction
of the slope you know where the
next point is going to be.
So you go to that -- just think
a tiny -- now this gets a
problem in a computer.
If the thing is really going
like this and you take a finite
step, the slope will have
changed during your step and you
won't get it just right.
So you'll have to take smaller
and smaller steps so that it
doesn't change during the step.
Chenyu?
Student:
>
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  Are you saying
that the curvature is a second
derivative?
Prof: Yes,
the curvature is a second
derivative, yes.
Student:  How do we
start with the correct slope?
Prof: We'll get to that.
But if you have the initial
slope, and the initial height,
then you use the formula for
the curvature to trace out the
curve.
Everybody got that now?
Okay, so that's great,
and it would be tedious to do
this by hand,
but that's what this little
program,
Erwin Meets Goldilocks,
does is start the curve and
draw it out,
according to what -- if you
know everything else in the
equation.
Okay, so, and remember it
curves away from zero when the
potential energy is greater than
the total energy,
and it curves towards zero when
the potential energy is less
than the total energy.
Right?
So the potential energy being
greater than the total energy is
a bad situation intuitively,
right, it means the kinetic
energy is negative,
and it curves away from the
baseline.
And what's bad about that,
or dangerous about that?
Yes, Kevin?
Pardon me?
Student:  It's not
bounded.
Prof: Yes,
it'll keep going until it gets
to infinity, if it's curving
away.
Okay, and that's not allowed,
it has to not go to infinity.
Okay, so now do we know
everything else?
Well we know m, the mass.
We know the constant,
C, and the V is
given to us, the potential
energy changes with position.
Right?
But we know how it changes with
position;
it's Coulomb's law typically,
or we can do some other law if
we want to.
So this recipe then,
you know everything on the
right, except the total energy.
Ψ you don't care
about because you can scale it,
you can make it anything you
want, call it one.
Okay?
Then we can double it if we
want to or whatever.
So Ψ we know;
m we know;
C we know;
V we know.
We're going to guess E.
So that means if we know the
initial slope --
and for the problems we work on
the initial slope will be zero,
and you'll see why -- then we
can use this formula to trace
out the curve.
Okay?
And that's what the computer
does for you.
So people were worried last
night about math.
Don't worry about math.
Let the computer calculate how
these slopes change and so on.
Right?
All you have to do is think
about the curvature.
Okay?
So you just have to think about
the graph.
Okay, so we're going to talk
now about nodes and
quantization,
in one dimension,
using this program Erwin
Meets Goldilocks.
And there's a problem set for
Monday,
as you know,
where you do this,
and the answers are on the
Wiki,
but don't look at them before
you've given it a good try.
Okay, so let's -- there are
simpler things to start with,
like a constant potential
energy or running into a wall or
into a pillow more like.
But the harmonic oscillator,
or Hooke's law,
is a very popular one to do;
so we're going to do that.
Okay, so here we're looking at
the potential energy as a
function of distance.
And also on the -- so you see
the distance goes from zero to
two and a half angstroms and the
potential energy goes from zero
to 100 kilocalories per mole.
You can change that if you want
to on the computer.
Okay?
And the horizontal black line
is a completely different plot.
It's a plot of Ψ.
That's the plot on top of this
one where we're going to trace
out the wavefunction.
Okay?
And that's zero of the
wavefunction;
here's zero of energy.
Okay?
And the reason we put them on
top of one another is so that
it's easy to see the influence
of one on the other,
of the wavefunction on the
potential energy and vice-versa,
and because they're functions
of the same thing.
What's Ψ a function
of?
What's it a function of?
Students:  Position.
Prof: It's a function of
the position.
Position of what?
The one particle we're talking
about.
Okay?
And the potential energy is
also a function of the position.
Okay, so the way we're going to
do this then is to guess an
energy, let the computer trace
out this curve,
and see whether it's okay.
What will tell us whether it's
okay?
How will we know if it's okay?
It's got to be continuous.
We're not going to have a
problem with that because the
computer is tracing it out this
way;
it's not going to be
discontinuous.
But the main thing is that it
doesn't diverge,
that it doesn't go to infinity.
Okay, so let's just guess
twenty-one kcal/mole.
Why not?
Okay, now you can already tell
me something about what the
curve is going to look like.
Notice that at those two
distances, between these two
distances, the total energy is
higher than the potential
energy.
What's the curve going to look
like in that region?
The kinetic energy is going to
be positive, right?
What will the curve look like?
Pat?
Student:  Spike up in
between them.
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  It's going to
spike up in between those two
lines.
Prof: It may go up,
it may go down.
Yes?
Pardon me?
It's not -- would it be a sine
curve?
Does anybody think it wouldn't
be a sine curve?
Why not Russell?
Student:  It does
sinusoidal behavior when the
potential is constant.
Prof: That's when the
It's not constant through here.
Right?
So it won't be an exact sine
curve.
If this isn't very high,
it might be close to a sine
curve because it's sort of
constant-ish,
if this is a very small
distance.
But what characteristic must it
have?
Student:  It'll curve
towards zero.
Prof: Say it again.
Student:  It'll curve
towards zero.
Prof: It'll curve
So it might -- it'll look
something like this.
Always -- it's curving and
going up and down,
maybe going high,
but it's always curving to go
back toward the baseline.
It's never going to go to
infinity.
Okay?
Now, there's a problem,
because if you go the other
way,
the rest of the graph,
the kinetic energy is negative
because the potential's higher
than the total.
So in that region there's great
danger that the line is going to
go to infinity,
because it's going to be
curving away from the baseline.
Okay?
Now how could you possibly
avoid that?
How could you have it such that
the curvature divided by the
value of the wavefunction gets
very big and the curvature away
from the baseline,
but still it doesn't go to
infinity?
How can the kinetic energy be
big and negative,
the curvature divided by the
value is enormous,
but it doesn't go to infinity?
How can that be?
Student:  Do we have to
bound it?
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  Bound.
Prof: Bound?
Student:  Yeah bound
what we're looking at?
Prof: No,
it's not a question of bound.
This thing is,
the particle,
if it has this total energy,
is bounded, it can't go all the
way to the left or the right,
that's true enough.
Okay, but that's not the secret
of how the wavefunction avoids
going to infinity.
Yeah?
Student:  Make it a
constant.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  Make it a
constant.
Prof: We can't -- make
what a constant?
Student:  Like --
another one a little bit.
Prof: Okay.
Russell?
Student:  You'd have
very little curvature.
Prof: But -- you say
But the kinetic energy is
enormous.
The curvature divided by the
value of the wavefunction has to
be enormous.
Mike?
Student:  You could make
the value of the wave function
go to zero.
Prof: Ah,
if the value of the
wavefunction is almost zero,
then you can have an enormous
-- pardon me,
wait a minute -- then you can
have a tiny numerator,
hardly any curvature at all,
and still the quotient can be
big.
Right?
The kinetic energy can be
enormous, and negative,
if the denominator is near
zero.
So that means that if you're in
those red regions,
you know what the wavefunction
has to look like.
What does it have to look like?
It has to get down near zero
and stay there so that it
doesn't have the curvature
that'll -- enough curvature to
pull it away.
So it's got to look like that,
on the left.
Right?
Because out here,
that parabola is going way up;
it's enormous,
curvature divided by
wavefunction,
but if the wavefunction is
essentially zero,
still the curvature can be
essentially zero.
Okay?
And the same on the right.
So we know that the curve is
going to look like this,
something like that.
Okay?
And all we have to do is
connect the pieces.
Okay, so let's try it.
We guessed twenty-one kcal/mole.
This we did in our head,
just by thinking about it.
But let's let the program do
it, and start at the left.
And now do you see why it has
to start with zero slope?
Because if it's out in this
region and has a finite slope,
or an appreciable slope,
and it's curving away,
you're in trouble,
because it's going to go to
infinity.
So we're going to use Erwin
Meets Goldilocks,
this program,
and we're going to start at --
here goes the curve,
and there's the part where the
kinetic energy is negative,
right?
It hasn't gone to infinity
because it started low enough
and with low enough slope out at
the left.
Okay, now what's going to
happen when it crosses that
line?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: What?
Student:  The curvature
changes.
Student:  Now the
curvature is going to be toward
the baseline,
as we guessed it would be;
so like that.
And now what's going to happen?
Now it's going to start curving
away from the baseline again.
Uh oh, you don't win them all,
right?
Okay, now did we have too much
energy or too little energy
here?
Notice that -- what did we want
it to do on the right?
On the left is where we
started, that looks great,
but on the right we're having
trouble.
What do you need to do in the
middle in order for it to behave
okay on the right?
It has to not curve so much
toward the baseline.
Does everybody see what I'm
saying?
If it curved less,
then it could join that other
line we had originally.
Okay, so we'll give it a little
less energy.
Let's try twenty.
That's too hot, too much energy.
Okay, so we'll guess twenty
kcal/mole.
Okay, here we go.
Start out;
almost exactly the same,
it's nearly the same energy,
so it doesn't surprise you that
it looks about the same.
And then it's going to curve in
here, the way we expected,
but a little bit less than it
did before.
Right?
So now we're on the way to
success.
So what was that one?
Student:  Too cold.
Prof: Too cold.
And what do you need?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Someplace in
between these,
there's going to be one that's
right.
Okay?
So it's between twenty and
twenty-one.
Now should we guess halfway
between twenty and twenty-one,
is that the reasonable thing to
do?
Which original guess was better?
Which guess was better
originally, and why?
The red one or the blue one,
which guess was better?
Student:  The red one.
Prof: Why was the red
one better?
Student:  Because it
curved close to the baseline.
Prof: It lasted longer
before it went to infinity.
So it'll be closer to the red
than to the blue.
And if you fiddle around -- and
that's what I want you to do,
because this is the way I think
it gets into your head is by
guessing numbers and saying
"where should I make the
next guess?"
and so on.
After you've done this a
certain number of times --
but enough times that it really
gets into your bones and your
brain --
after you've done it enough
times,
then you can use the function
that says "Solve"
and it will do that guessing
game for you.
But do it yourself at the
beginning.
Okay, and it turns out that
after you've done that,
you get 20.74 da-da-da-da-da,
like a lot of decimal points,
decimal positions,
and you get that one,
just right.
Okay?
So that's the only math you
need to do.
Is it too hot or too cold or
just right?
Okay?
And you have to know why it has
to be that way,
because of this curvature
thing.
Okay, so there we have it,
20.74 kcal/mole is a
satisfactory energy,
and it comes with this
wavefunction,
whatever that's good for.
Okay?
But the energy is what we were
looking at, what energies are
allowed for this system?
Now, could there be a lower
energy allowed for this system?
Could you imagine a less curved
wavefunction that would also
have this property of not going
to infinity?
Can somebody guess what it
would look like?
Nick?
Student:  You'd have one
that would just go up.
Prof: Ah,
it could just go up and then
come back to the baseline --
it has to come back to the
baseline --
but it could just go up rather
than curving so much in the
middle.
Okay, so we guess a lower one.
Could there be a lower energy
Ψ?
Yes indeed, there could be one
at 4.15 -- it's actually
.149-something-or-another,
to a lot of decimal points.
And there it is,
exactly what Nick expected.
Okay, so you got this.
Could there be a still lower
one?
Student:  Yes,
well in between the two.
Prof: Not in between.
Can there be one lower than the
blue?
Student:
>
Prof: Can you imagine a
way to get it even lower than
the blue, an even lower
curvature than the blue?
Yes, Angela?
Pardon me?
Student:  What if it
curved, like the one --
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  If the blue
one is going up,
then there could be one going
down.
Prof: Ah,
there could be an upside-down
blue one;
absolutely true,
there could be an upside-down
blue one, but it's the same
thing, because it's the blue one
multiplied by minus one.
Remember, you can multiply it
by any number and it's still the
same thing.
Right?
So it's exactly the same energy.
It's not a different
wavefunction,
it's just multiplied by a
constant.
But you're right,
that also does the trick,
but it turns out to be the same
thing.
Can you imagine anything lower
in energy than this?
It's impossible,
because if it had less
curvature in the middle,
it's bound to go to infinity
when it got back in the other
region.
Okay, so that's -- the blue is
the lowest one.
Now could there be one in
between these two?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: How?
It looks like -- how could you
do it?
Yes, Kevin?
Student:  One peak is
above the value and one peak --
Prof: Ah,
one peak above and one below.
Right?
Could there be an energy in
between?
Yes indeed, there could be that
one.
Now could there be others in
between?
What happens as you add
curvature?
You have these nodes.
A node is where the
wavefunction is zero.
It's not a node out here,
where it's almost zero.
A node is when it's exactly
zero, and it has to be zero
because it's going from being
positive to being negative;
obviously it has to go through
zero.
Out here, and out there,
it's very, very,
very small but it's not zero;
that's not a node.
A node is where it's zero
because it's changing sign.
Okay, now nodes are related to
energy.
Why?
Notice that the lowest energy
one, blue, had no node,
the next one,
the purple, had one node.
The next one,
the violet or whatever color it
is, had two nodes.
Why is there that relationship?
Student:  I was noticing
inflection points.
Prof: They are
inflection points,
but why do they get higher in
energy when you have more nodes?
Sam?
Student:  Higher
frequency.
Prof: Say it in terms of
energy.
Some people would say frequency
is energy, that's true,
but I want you to say it terms
we've been talking about.
How do you get more nodes?
Yeah?
Student:  A higher
absolute value of curvature.
Prof: Yes,
if the curvature gets bigger,
you get more nodes,
and curvature is the energy,
the kinetic energy.
Right?
So more curvature,
more nodes, more energy;
or more energy,
more curvature,
more nodes.
So we have zero nodes,
one node, two nodes.
Those are the lowest three you
can get.
And then there would be three
nodes, four nodes,
five nodes, six nodes,
as many nodes as you want.
Okay, now this is great.
You can do all sorts of neat
tricks for Monday,
and what I want you to do with
this program is just to fiddle
around with it and make
discoveries for yourself.
And I'll show you some of the
kinds of discoveries that you
can do in the next slides here.
But I warn you that if you have
more dimensions,
or more particles,
things quickly become
impossible.
The only thing you can do this
particular approach with is one
particle and one dimension,
because if you have more,
then you don't know which
curvature to change.
You know the curvature --
remember,
it's a sum of a bunch of
curvatures,
and knowing the kinetic energy,
the difference between total
and potential,
doesn't tell you which
curvature to change.
If there's only one then you
know that that's the one you
have to do.
So it's going to be a heck of a
lot of work to do this for more
complicated systems.
Right?
And that's not our purpose now.
Our purpose is to understand
how quantum mechanics works with
this simple system.
But the question is,
is it going to be worth our
effort to learn how it works if
we're unable to do anything with
it?
Or another way of putting it
is, "What's the reward,
what are we going to get out of
this?
Is it worth spending some time
on?"
Well, here's the reward for
finding Ψ.
>
The knowledge of everything.
Okay?
For example,
you know what energies are
allowed to a system;
you know what the structures
can be;
you know how it behaves
dynamically, how it moves;
you know how bonds work --
that's what we're really after,
remember?
And you know what makes for
reactivity.
So there's a pretty good pot of
gold at the end of this.
So fasten your seatbelts and
put your nose to the grindstone
and all sorts of metaphors,
and we'll do this for the next
couple of weeks.
Okay?
First we'll look at allowed
energies and structure.
Okay now, of course,
we already did this,
right?
No nodes, one node, two nodes.
But what were the energies that
were allowed?
Okay, so here's a whole bunch
of them.
No nodes, one node,
two nodes, three nodes,
up to seven nodes or -- is it
seven?;
yes seven nodes.
Now here are the energies:
4.15,12.44,20.74,29.04,37.34.
Do you see any pattern to the
energies?
You might read the title if you
have trouble seeing it.
They're evenly spaced;
after the first one they're
evenly spaced.
How about the first one
compared with zero?
How high is the first one if
you know this spacing?
Students:  Half.
Prof: It's half.
The first one above zero is
half as big as the spacing of
the others.
Right?
So the energy is some constant,
and that constant is what?
8.3 roughly,
times an integer minus a half.
Why do you have integers?
Because nodes come in integers;
you can't have half a node,
right?
It's zero nodes,
one, two, three,
four and so on.
Okay?
So that's pretty great.
We know for springs,
or harmonic oscillators,
or an atom stuck on a bond,
as long as the potential --
it doesn't vibrate so much that
the potential deviates from
looking like a parabola;
at the bottom of the curve it
looks like a parabola.
So this is the way atoms should
behave when they're attached by
bonds -- approximately.
Okay, now remember that
doggerel poem from 1926:
"We only wish that we
could glean an inkling of what
Ψ could mean."
What have we used Ψ
for so far?
Student:
>
Prof: We used it -- its
not going to infinity -- to find
out when we guessed the energy
right.
It was just a tool for telling
us whether we had the right
energy.
But does Ψ really
mean something,
besides just being a handy tool
for this purpose?
And it was later,
six months later,
in 1926, that it was suggested
what the meaning of it was.
And it was in this paper by Max
Born that the --
Ψ doesn't mean
anything,
but Ψ^2 is
probability density,
or proportional to probability
density.
If you scale it right --
remember you can scale
Ψ by -- multiply it
by any number you want.
If you scale it right,
it is the probability density
of the particle.
Now here's what he wrote in
German,
and what it says is:
"If one wishes to
translate this result into
physical terms,
only one interpretation is
possible,
Ψ signifies the
probability ."
But there's a footnote there,
because he made a mistake,
and he corrected it after the
thing was already set in type.
So he put a footnote here which
says: "A correction added
in proof: more careful
consideration shows that the
probably is proportional to the
square of
Ψ."
Why couldn't it be -- why
couldn't the probability be
proportional to Ψ?
Because Ψ can be
negative!
You can't have a
negative…
Well that's one reason.
There were other reasons too.
I don't know how embarrassed he
was by this,
but anyhow -- but since nobody
else knew what Ψ was
at all,
I think he could be proud
nonetheless, right?
But anyhow, it's the square of
Ψ,
not Ψ itself,
that gives probability density.
Now, six months later Albert
Einstein wrote a letter to Max
Born where he said something
you've probably heard:
"But an inner voice tells
me that this is not the real
thing.
Theory yields a great deal,
but it brings us no nearer to
the secret of the Old One.
Anyway I am convinced that He
does not play dice."
Right?
So it's not probabilities.
There's this fundamental
determinism, Einstein thinks.
But it turned out that in this
respect Einstein was wrong.
Right?
It is probability.
Now, it's not probability,
it's probability density,
and we have to think a little
bit about this,
and we can think of it in -- by
analogy,
with mass density.
Suppose you had a flask and it
had mercury and water and oil in
it, right?
And you're going to ask the
question,
if the total mask in the flask
is one kilogram,
what fraction of that,
or how much weight,
is exactly one centimeter from
the bottom?
How many grams,
or what fraction of the total
do you think,
would be exactly one centimeter
from the bottom?
Anybody got a guess?
5%, 1%, ½%, 10%?
Student:  12%.
Prof: 12%?
Student:  Three.
Prof: There'll be --
this'll be an auction,
right?
Do I hear higher than 12%?
Do I hear lower than 12%?
Who's bidding?
Yes, what do you say?
Student:  Zero.
Prof: Zero?
Student: It's an exact
value.
Prof: Why zero?
Well obviously it has to do --
different heights would have
different densities,
right?
So it'd be a lot more in
mercury than it would if I drew
the line in oil or in water,
right?
But you say zero.
Why?
Student:  Because it's
an exact value.
It won't have --
Prof: Right.
A plane, or a line,
or a dot doesn't have any
volume.
Right?
You need a volume -- it's zero,
you're right,
you need a volume.
You have to multiply density,
grams per cubic centimeter by
volume, how many cubic
centimeters, in order to get
mass.
And the same is true of -- so
that in this case the real
question would be how much is
between one centimeter and 1.01
centimeters,
or something like that?
You could ask that question,
but you can't say how much is
exactly one centimeter?
So you have to multiply by
volume, multiply density by
volume, to get the amount.
Right?
And so Ψ^2 is
probability density.
It's how probable it is to be
in a small volume,
a unit volume,
around the point in question.
So you go to some point in
question,
square Ψ,
find the density,
multiply it by the volume over
which Ψ is constant
--
because it doesn't vary real
rapidly,
so you could choose a really
small one --
multiply, and that's the
probability of being in that
little block.
Right?
Now, remember we said you could
multiply,
you could scale Ψ by
any constant you wanted to,
even minus one or -p or
whatever.
Okay?
Is there a good value,
a preferred value to scale it
by?
You could scale it by such a
number that when it's squared
and you've multiplied by volume
over every place,
sum up all these little boxes,
you get one.
Why do you want to get one?
Because the total probability
is one that it's someplace,
right?
So that process is called
normalization.
We don't usually worry about
that, right?
We usually just take whatever
numbers we want,
that's convenient to plot on
the graph,
and know that we have to scale
it such that if we want to
calculate actual probability
density that's going to sum to
one.
Okay, so here's an example
where above we show two of these
curves and below we show squares
of those, not properly scaled
together.
There's, I think,
a little more area in the red
than in the blue,
although maybe I'm bad.
They should have the same area,
if the thing were normalized.
Okay, so that shows what it is.
Now there's an interesting
thing about that.
If you have a pendulum,
or a thing on a spring,
and it's going back and forth,
where does it spend most of its
time?
Student:  Extremes.
Prof: At the extremes,
because it's going so slow
there.
Right?
In the blue one where does it
spend most of its time?
Where does it spend most of its
time?
Where is it most dense if it's
the blue wavefunction,
the lowest wavefunction,
the zero-node wavefunction?
Obviously it spends its time in
the middle, not at the extremes.
But notice if you get to the
seventh wavefunction;
one, two, three,
four, five, six,
seven;
the seventh wavefunction is
going to have seven humps --
that then it's most probable at
the extremes,
and as it gets -- as you get
higher and higher it gets more
and more focused at the
extremes,
and that's why when you get to
something that's really heavy it
behaves the way you expect a
pendulum or a thing on a spring
to behave.
Okay?
This is not normalized.
But notice something else
that's really valuable here,
really crucial,
which is that this line is
where the potential and the
total are the same for the red
curve.
Right?
So here is zero kinetic energy.
In here the kinetic energy is
positive, out here it's
negative, and the thing can be
out here.
Right?
So the thing exists in a region
of negative kinetic energy.
There's nothing special about
that.
Okay?
It's just that that's the way
things work.
Kinetic energy can be negative.
And in the case of the blue
one, here was the point where
the kinetic energy was zero,
and all this out here is
probability in a region of
negative kinetic energy.
Now, what if we do it with a
Morse potential?
Notice if we look at the first
one with a Morse potential,
it looks the same as it would
in a Hooke's-law harmonic
oscillator.
Does that surprise you?
No, because the potential looks
that way, pretty much.
Right?
But as you go higher and higher
and get here to whatever that
is,
the twelfth or something like
that,
you can see that it's very
different and it's spending a
lot of time far out.
It's shifting its average to
the right.
But that doesn't surprise you
because the well moves out to
the right,
as you move up,
in the Morse potential,
as you move to higher energy,
because low kinetic energy,
which is what you have as you
move to the right,
means low curvature.
Why does that make it high
probability?
Because as long as you have
high
curvature-over-wavefunction,
whenever the wavefunction peeks
up, it gets pulled down again;
it can't stay up.
But if you have very low
curvature toward the baseline,
very low kinetic energy,
then it can go up and you don't
mind,
because the kinetic -- you
don't need much curvature when
the wavefunction is big.
Okay, so it's like that,
and then out in here it's
pretty much like an exponential
decay.
Does that surprise you?
Kate you look like it didn't
surprise you.
Student:  No it didn't.
Prof: Why not?
When do you expect the
wavefunction to be an
exponential decay,
under what condition?
Student: When the
potential energy --
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  When the
potential energy is constant.
Prof: Ah,
when the potential energy is
constant, and what else to be
exponential?
The sine wave is also constant.
Student:  Right,
but it has to be --
Prof: Right?
What makes it exponential,
rather than a sine wave?
Yes?
Student:  Negative
kinetic energy.
Prof: Ah,
the kinetic energy is negative,
the potential's higher than the
total.
But that's exactly the case on
the right, because there's the
potential, there's the total,
and the kinetic energy is going
down;
it's negative,
the difference between the two.
Okay?
Now, here are a whole bunch of
these for the harmonic -- for
the Morse potential.
How does it look different from
Hooke's law?
Does the spacing of energies
look the same as it did in
Hooke's law?
Again, it's zero nodes,
one, two, three,
four and so on.
But how is it different?
Yes?
Student:
>
Prof: Ah,
the spacing gets closer as you
go up.
So real bonds,
which have a potential that
looks more like this than like a
spring,
will have their energy levels
get closer as you get more and
more vibrational energy.
Okay, they're not evenly spaced
as they are for Hooke's law.
As the energy increases,
along with the number of nodes,
the well widens more than it
would for Hooke's-law parabola.
So the wavelengths become
longer, those nodes are spaced
over a bigger distance,
and the energies are lower than
expected for Hooke's law,
because you don't have as much
curvature.
You have the same number of
nodes --
like the eighteenth level has
the same number of nodes as it
would in Hooke's law,
but they're spaced over a wider
distance,
so there's less curvature,
so the energy doesn't go up as
much.
Okay now, this is interesting.
Look if you have the blue
energy.
Right?
Now the wavefunction looks like
this.
It's no longer bounded.
Does it surprise you that the
wavefunction goes on out to
infinity when the total energy
is higher than that potential
energy at the right?
No.
It means you have enough energy
to break the bond.
So the particle could just keep
going.
Okay, now what does this look
like?
In this region it looks like it
does in a Hooke's law or
something like that,
more or less.
What does it look like out at
the right?
It's a sine wave. Why?
Sam, does that surprise you
that it looks like a sine wave?
Student:  Because the
potential is just --
Prof: Ah,
the potential is constant,
effectively constant out there,
and lower than the total.
So it's a constant.
It's about a sine wave because
you have a constant positive
kinetic energy when the total
energy is above that
dissociation limit.
So there's the potential,
there's the total,
and now the kinetic energy is
positive and about constant,
so it's approximately a sine
wave.
Okay, now Coulombic potential
is a more complicated one.
The reason it's complicated is
the energy goes to infinity when
r becomes zero;
when the positive and the
negative are on top of one
another it becomes infinitely
favorable.
So it's hard to do this
numerically, and the program
will screw up sometimes when you
try to do Coulombic potential.
And it's one-dimensional,
and it turns out,
curiously enough,
that the system is simpler in
three dimensions than in one
dimension,
for a Coulombic potential.
Don't worry about the technical
aspects of that.
But at any rate,
this is using the program for
that,
and you can see that the lowest
-- that you have very,
very high curvature when you
get near zero because you have
such high kinetic energy when
the particles get very close to
one another,
and because the Erwin program
is approximate,
taking finite steps,
you get in trouble often.
Okay, but anyhow you get the
idea that again as you get
higher energy,
you get waves that spread out.
And they spread out a lot for
the same reason they did in
Morse potential,
although here we're using a
much lighter mass,
we're using an electron.
Right?
But it spreads out much more
because the well spreads out so
much.
Okay?
So higher levels spread way
out, and now the sequence of
energies -- here's the lowest,
the next and the next.
You have a big spacing first
and then it gets much,
much smaller.
It turns out that the energy is
some constant divided by
n^2.
So the number one level has an
energy of -k,
the next one is
-¼k.
The blue line is only a fourth
as far down as the green,
from zero, which is up at the
top.
Well zero is that grey line at
the top, because it keeps going
out to zero far out there.
And the next one is 1/9th of
the way from the top to the
lowest level.
So the reward for finding
Ψ was "the
knowledge of everything."
We've seen the allowed energy
and structure.
Now we're going to see another
case where we get structure and
we also see something about
dynamics that's interesting,
about the motion of the atoms.
So here's -- suppose this is a
proton attached by a bond to
something that's heavy.
So the heavy thing doesn't
move, the hydrogen does the
moving.
Okay?
And here's its wavefunction.
This is the bond distance,
the minimum energy.
If you stretch the bond the
energy goes up;
if you compress the bond the
energy goes up.
And that's the wavefunction for
the position of the hydrogen
atom.
Right?
Now suppose we increase the
mass and instead of talking
about a hydrogen atom we talked
about a carbon atom which had
say fourteen,
depending on which isotope
we're using --
suppose we went to fourteen.
How is that going to change
things, if we have mass -- can
we use the same function,
if we use mass of fourteen?
Notice that we're using the
same potential.
So the kinetic energy at any
point is going to be the same
for the two.
How does mass enter into
kinetic energy?
Yes?
Student:  Would it be
more concentrated?
Prof: Can't hear.
Student:  Would it be
more concentrated?
Prof: Why do you say it
would be more concentrated?
What would make it more
concentrated?
Student:  Higher nuclear
charge, so the electrons would
want to--;
Prof: Yes,
but you're not thinking about
quantum mechanics.
You're thinking that the higher
-- well no, wait a second,
we're not talking nuclear
charge here.
All we're talking is mass.
It's held by a spring,
we're thinking,
okay?
So electrostatics doesn't come
into it, it's a spring that's
stretching.
Elizabeth?
Student:  In that
equation that you showed us
before, the curvature is
proportional to mass?
Prof: Yes,
the kinetic energy has one over
mass in it.
So if you increase the mass,
and keep the same wave,
what are you going to do to the
energy?
Student:  Decrease.
Prof: You're going to
decrease the energy.
But it's the same energy as it
was for hydrogen.
You can't just decrease the
energy, at a given position,
if you know the total.
Okay, so you want it to be --
to get the same energy it has to
be more curved.
Okay, everybody with me?
To have the same energy,
if you have a bigger mass in
the denominator,
you're going to have more
curvature,
fourteen times as much
curvature, to compensate for the
bigger mass.
So it's going to curve more
toward the baseline.
Okay?
So if we used that same energy
and had the higher mass,
so we got more curvature for
the same energy,
then it's going to curve a lot
more,
it's going to go through and go
up to infinity,
and it's even higher energy
than the second wave would be.
It's curved way too much.
So how would you find the
lowest energy,
what would you do in your
guessing?
If you wanted to find the
lowest energy what would you do?
You'd lower your guess to make
it less curved toward the
baseline.
Okay?
And if you do that,
so lower the energy,
from that, and there we've got
the answer.
Right?
So hydrogen has a much higher
vibrational energy than carbon
does for the same bond,
to get the lowest energy.
I think this will be clear to
you when you have time to think
about it.
If not, ask questions.
Okay?
Now what if you had U-235 or a
marble at the end of the same
spring?
What do you think its
wavefunction would look like,
the lowest energy wavefunction?
Student:  A spike.
Prof: It's just a spike.
The heavier it is,
the narrower it gets.
Right?
So if you have something like a
baseball held by a bond,
it's going to sit right there.
You're not going to be able to
see that it's spread out.
But electrons are so much
lighter than nuclei that
electrons really spread out.
Okay, now so there are the
probability distributions for
hydrogen and for carbon,
held by a single bond.
Why is their average not in the
same position?
See what I mean?
Elizabeth?
Pardon?
Student:  Acceleration
has to do with mass.
Prof: No, no.
It has to do -- yes?
Student:  Because the
electrons are not attracted
equally.
Prof: No,
no, it's -- remember,
electrons aren't entering into
this.
We're just supposing that we
have a nucleus held by a spring
and that spring is the strength
of a single-bond.
Okay?
What is the potential for a
bond?
Is it Hooke's law?
What's a better potential for a
bond than Hooke's law?
Students:
Morse potential.
Prof: The Morse
potential, which broadens out,
remember, as it goes up.
So since hydrogen goes up more,
it samples further out to the
right, so it's displaced to the
right from the carbon.
Okay?
Now so let's -- here they are
at their minimum energy
position, and they vibrate.
The higher energy is shifted to
the right in the unsymmetrical
Morse potential.
And here's the half-maximum of
the -- so it spends -- it's half
as probable -- the probability
density here is half what it is
there.
So when you say,
how far does it spread out?
This thing goes out to infinity.
But we can talk about how wide
it is by saying how wide it is
at half-height.
So the hydrogen at half-height
is from here to here,
but the carbon at half-height
is only from there to there;
that is, if you think of these
things vibrating,
the hydrogen has a bigger
amplitude than carbon,
because it's lighter.
So the hydrogen vibrates by 0.1
angstrom, 9% of the distance.
The carbon vibrates only half
as much, 3% of the carbon-X
distance, just because of the
mass difference.
And remember we said before,
last time, that typically the
atoms are vibrating by about
0.05 angstroms in the crystal.
That's where this came from,
it's this quantum mechanical
thing.
That's the least that they can
-- and when they're in their
lowest possible energy state
they vibrate by that much,
right?
And that's how much it is,
that little yellow dot after it
shrank.
So we've seen allowed energies
and structure.
We've seen dynamics,
the vibration.
Now, next time,
we're going to look at
dynamics, and also the payoff,
bonding, how we understand
bonding in one dimension.